I think what I look for in a part is a
challenge and I really like to mix it up
you know try and do something different
from what I've previously done and I
also you know look out further writers
and the cast - I could be possibly
working alongside and soon with
directors just people who are who I
would like to work with and yeah there's
something different in each role is my
biggest my biggest aim I would say I
think preparing for a role varies
depending on the part like I've just
finished a big period drama so there was
a lot of research that went into the
history and was 13 I researched you know
stories of victims who've been kidnapped
so I think it depends on on the project
and but I do kind of leave a lot for the
day
I kind of believe a lot that happens in
the moment I think you can only do so
much and then you've got to just let it
be and yeah
I think collaboration is very led by the
people you're working words I think
everyone has their own way of working
and that's what's amazing about being on
set as you learn a lot about people and
you know people have their own some
people have to get in the zone like some
people you know can jump in and out of
character so it's like being respectful
of what everyone's kind of processes I
think I'm just very open you know I
think and I think once you actors are
very open and and you know what for
trying things and and you know trusted
each other I think that's when you get
the best ice to work out of people
directors are the same you know of every
rural human and everyone is very
different so directors can have very
different approaches on you know you
could go on a job and the director has a
whole different idea of what this
character is like or where she is in
this particular part of the story and
then it's up to you guys to discuss her
and maybe try it one way and and try out
your there and usually there's like a
middle ground or sometimes you realize
that yet you were probably wrong so I
think it's always nice to be given the
opportunity by a director to you know to
have your sayin and bring your ideas to
play the paranoia always make friends
with fast is usually the costumes done
by and Maya Gibbs who is my costume
standby on the way princess seen me at
my way there with me all the time like
dressing me undressing me like you get
very close to those people because
they're with you a lot and and they're
kind of looking after you so yeah I
would say costumes done by a the people
I initially get very very close to
patrons always a good one as well a lot
of people say caterer you get an extra a
bigger slice of cake or you know always
prove when I was 16 I had to leave my
first agent my mom and dad have been
very good in kind of taken aback she
always been there to support people
always kind of making sure that I take
the room so I remember having to ring my
first agent when I was like 15 16 and
tell them that I was leavin
which at the time was huge but I think
I kind of realized that I had to grow up
a lot and I had to take responsibility
for and know my own decisions and I
think that's played a massive part in my
career I've always kind of been
headstrong in the decisions that I make
and I've kind of trust my gut instincts
but yeah that was a big challenge and
then I think the everyday you know you
might do sanity auditions and you still
don't go I roll so there's a lot there's
a lot of rejection but you can't assault
by it and such a challenge I think as
I've gotten a little bit older I've
learned to let go a little bit more like
I still come out of an audition and go
why did I say that one like that when I
could have said at this site like I
think most people are the same and but
as I've got older another better at
going okay well if it works out it's
meant to be if it doesn't then that's
fine as a lot of the time you don't hear
if you haven't got it it's just kind of
like okay but I didn't go my way I said
I have you know like brushing brushing
your shoulders off and going into the
next song with the positive attitude I
have spent a lot of time looking at what
other people are doing in their careers
and compared it and I don't think that's
healthy I think you know you're on your
own track just concentrate on yourself
and can't yeah don't worry about what
anyone else is doing think that's what
yeah what my advice would be
you